[Music]
so obviously tough times right now with
with coronavirus everyone's super
concerned and I bet one question a lot
of you guys have is what what masks do I
get do they work or you know what am I
supposed to be buying so I can't tell
you which masks you should get but at
least I can give you some information so
that you can make as informed of a
decision as you can the ones that you
see most often are surgical masks or
otherwise known as your loot masks so
let let me show you how to put one on
this is what they look like you want to
make sure when you're putting him on the
color side is out wrap them around their
ears you want to make sure that there's
a metal bar right here and you want to
try to pinch it around your nose as well
as you can if you have facial hair if
you have a beard this will not work so
you got to make sure you shave and
you're using it properly but you want to
get a nice tight seal on these and then
you're gonna see different levels of
masks
you're gonna see sometimes level 1 level
2 level 3 you're like what does that
mean what does that mean what this is an
ASTM level they basically kind of
differentiate between the different
types of protection that they offer
now the pore sizes on these are
relatively the same this has more to do
with splatter like if you're working
with blood or or patients and you're
you're having different splatters level
1 it's just kind of a basic level 2
offers more protection and then level 3
is for heavy splatter it offers the most
protection but that's if liquid is
directly getting in contact with your
mask and in terms of filtration
efficiency level 1 is right around 95
percent whereas level 2 and level 3 are
gonna be at 98% what you care about what
the virus is pore sizes so they're all
relatively the same but viruses are
really really tiny they're they're
between like 50 and 500 nanometers for
the larger ones but they're really small
much smaller than the pore sizes here
you're just hoping that the viruses
adhere on to larger particles and get
trapped on your mess
that's why it's not like a hundred
percent protection but they do offer
some protection that's also why you
don't want to keep your mask and reuse
it for too long because eventually if
you're touching it and pushing it and
there's virus on there and then that's
gonna eventually get to you so these are
disposable you keep wearing them over
and over again you're not being
protected so that's a good thing to keep
in mind and here you know you don't know
where these masks are coming from and
you know if you see a level 1 or level 2
or level 3 you know it is what it is but
a simple test you can do is the water
test you want to make sure a mask
doesn't allow any water through so let's
get some water here and you can see I'm
pouring some over that essentially none
is getting through that's a decent mask
ok so now we've covered surgical masks
and now there's another level of a mask
that a lot of people ask about and those
are the n95 respirator masks it's
generally a common thought that n95
masks perform better but do they really
so let's take a look at it this is what
an n95 mask looks like let me show you
guys how to put this on you have two
straps and you take both straps and you
put them around your head and you want
to make sure that this nose portion is
nice and snug so the one nice thing
about the respirator masks is you get a
much better seal around your mouth area
but in terms of particle filtration
efficiency
this one's rated at 95% they're roughly
about the same between a 95 mass in the
surgical masks they have kind of
differences pros and cons those are a
little bit more easy to use but they all
work wearing a mask works now with n95
you'll see a lot of different types of
specifications for these n95 that's like
an American standard for NIOSH there you
will also see something like K in 95 and
you're like well there's a difference
between a 95 and a canine and 95 well
they're just different standards but
they roughly all kind of equate to
filtering out 95% of particles around
0.3 microns and above there's other
types of standards as well like FFP too
that's kind of similar same thing
filtering out 95% so
people ask what's the difference between
a surgical mask and an n95 respirator
mask and which one is better
well the regulating bodies are different
the surgical masks are cleared by the
FDA whereas the ending 95 respirator
masks are tested and approved by NIOSH
they both have roughly the same
filtering efficiency from a particle
standpoint but the n95 respirator mask
as you see year's tight fitting it
actually provides proper respiratory
protection whereas the surgical mask
does not provide the wear with a
reliable level of protection film
particles does that mean the surgical
masks don't work actually they work
quite well you know if you fit them over
your face properly the NID pipe designed
to contour the face very well whereas a
surgical mask you just have to be really
careful about how you worried but the
takeaway is all masks work so regardless
if you're using the n95 or the surgical
mask it's a good idea to wear max height
well be safe and take care of yourselves
and do what you can in this crisis see
you later